una tradición que continúa
parís es la primera parada en el
exterior para el nuevo canciller alemán
olaf scholz llegó a la capital francesa
dos días después de jurar el cargo allí
se reunió con el presidente manuel
macrón una oportunidad para afianzar la
alianza entre ambos países
se que seguiremos juntos esta estrecha
coordinación querido olaf en cualquier
caso hoy hemos acordado varias
iniciativas comunes un deseo compartido
de trabajar juntos y avanzar en un marco
común johnson en la rueda de prensa a
pesar de algunas diferencias mostraron
su compromiso medioambiental
cada país tiene su perspectiva sobre
detener el cambio climático provocado
por el hombre lo que nos une es que
ambos vemos la obligación y compartimos
ambiciones
también hablaron de conflictos globales
como el que enfrenta rusia con ucrania
defendiendo el llamado formato de
normandía para el diálogo nivel el
próximo miércoles tendremos la
oportunidad de decidir sobre nuevas
iniciativas pero el formato de normandía
preserva su relevancia creo que permite
un proceso óptimo de trabajo entre y
rusia era hoy si no faltó espacio para
la gestión de las fronteras de la unión
europea tras los conflictos recientes
con belarús y reino unido para la
seguridad y la cooperación en europa
necesitan que las fronteras sean
inviolables y al mismo tiempo tenemos
que trabajar para asegurar que donde han
surgido conflictos se reduzcan estos
conflictos posturas comunes a las que se
les sumará pronto la del último reto
geopolítico el boicot diplomático contra
los juegos olímpicos de invierno beijing
2022 impulsado por eeuu y socios como
australia y canadá eje aliado pero del
que la unión europea busca más
independencia en esta nueva etapa de
olaf scholz como socio francés en el
liderazgo comunitario